se barbie dream house party sul mio
canale ha fatto quasi 4 milioni di
visualizzazioni quale voglio 10 10 ne
voglio guardate su quesiti di merda sto
andando per farvi video su showgirl
games punto com
questo è quello che chiamano il divo
web.la tutti ragazzi e beve rete questo
video sono fa vigili oggi siamo su un
gioco che si chiama james malick gate
simulator cena io io volevo quello di
james volevo rimorchiare non me ne frega
un cazzo di matrimonio principesse o
eccolo la difficoltà di questo gioco ed
è trovare il gioco per il primo bene
questo ed è in questa sono io
diamoci da fare hai vinto un
appuntamento allo zen e già questo è
fatto che un'asta al computer a casa
ogni tanto gli appare la scritta hai
vinto un appuntamento con zein non è un
virus di a e b è vero i personalizza la
tipa come mi chiamo armanda che cosa
piace ad malick vediamo successo mi
piace una ragazza che non si prende
troppo seriamente
i valori della vecchia scuola sono
importanti e che sia rispettoso ma
chissenefrega se ti piace che le tette
grosse o meno non gliene frega un cazzo
di queste che c'hai le prendi e le botti
ma facciamola quei miei gusti d'acqua in
poi sapete sapete cosa piace io non so
veramente da dove iniziare però oggi fa
vjd insegna come rimorchiare zayn malik
prendi il suo numero di telefono due
scopri il segreto tre fatti dare un
bacio da lui
ok ciao sono già in meno male credevo
fossi harry potter
ciao sono armanda ora il galles ed etna
mimì aimar manda wow this match su get
sei mesi quando approcciate una persona
conosciuta
l'ultima cosa che dovete fare va dove
l'ultima prima dovete morire puoi fare
questa cosa e agire come una fang rom
perché se io adesso facessi ormai da zio
sam raimi il tipo mi sputa in faccia
quindi aimar banda walt disney censo
games questa vuol dire che lo sfrutti
per diventare famosa perché fa di te una
trojan o che tu non lo sia già zia la
cosa giusta da fare adesso è a jan arman
da nice to meet you come sono skillato è
come ali di morchio questi uomini mi hai
detto abbastanza sud i tempi da parliamo
di me ma cosa hanno detto niente parole
ha detto nulla è un deficiente ed
efficiente credo di conoscerti meglio di
te stesso ma version per ok l'ex 2 days
facciamo questa va qualcosa in cambio
dai che tanto maschio non rifiuta qual è
la mia canzone preferita di sempre mi
chiamo anche lui michael jackson
thriller zio thriller poi tra l'altro la
più base di michael jackson prova o sei
brava vediamo se sei la prossima quanti
tatuaggi o quindi cimeli potresti far
vedere dopo o perfetto lo zio se una
ragazza ti sta rossello ti farò vedere i
miei se ti se mi fai vedere i tuoi i più
vecchi che come sono bravo a rimorchiare
t no cosa ma tutto ok e quello ci sono
io zia va bene sei anche rossa sposami
te li faccio vedere io e me tatuaggi
basta che mi amor questo qualche bello e
famigliari sbagliati
torna zengoni se è difficile mamma mia
che schifo allora proviamo stavolta ce
la posso fare ciao sono zein ciao sono
stern il rischio che la prima dovrebbe
andare bene già questa inter ea fa chi è
in elephant mute o mio dio fa me lo dire
a tutti i miei amici su facebook
certo poco questa clicco posso avere
anche il numero di harry se non te ne
vai adesso sei proprio stronzo sono
tenuti ad esso oh mio dio era gli piace
a tutti quanti più di me
macef poverino no dai
un cuore spezzato ragazzi mi dispiace mi
dispiace io sono innamorato di erri de
fatte nella ragione un po come se la mia
fan mi chiedesse tipo dopo un po il
numero di stefani cioè ok darmi un bacio
stronzo da me e bacio baciami la casa ha
baciata è una ragazza a new york e
chissenefrega tutto bagnato somma perché
non rimaniamo soltanto amici ma come è
finita la silvia freddo nata ma
[ __ ] james ma veramente ma dai che
cazzo hai jesus wow this is my next
gamers domani si sta facendo tardi buono
volchem in questa ora lo farei di certo
va bene fa sì che ti baci ma come non è
vero
stavo scherzando posso sentire la sua
lingua non è vero non lo sto sentendo e
non ci tengo pd tanto mano ok quindi ho
vinto è stato semplice è finito qua beh
guarda basta preval ragazzi a vedere su
google se riesco a trovare una roba tipo
che lo sa per lo sapevo che sarebbe
uscito lo sapevo
ascoltami non sei tanto capaci a
rimorchiare tipper pronti manca questa
cosa c'è nel senso tela te la tiri tanto
oggi farisei ti insegna messi di morchia
le fan
va bene è un po come come cucinare la
pasta passaggio numero uno.sono su comic
con
la parola chiave è in mali seconda cosa
da fare è in aspetti cinque minuti di
cottura 5 aspettati cinque minuti di
cottura vai su video e trovi le tipe ok
speriamo magari mi esce un omone gigante
però vabbè appunto
[Musica]
ciao accaniti sente di dirgli una cosa
tu devi rispondere solo si sono sì a
questa cosa ok ma vuoi essere la mia
ragazza
davvero film
era difficile non è capello estero
prestami segnando sei capace quindi
ragazzi questo era un rapido tutorial su
come rimorchiare le tipe adesso userò
questo tutorial io stesso per
rimorchiare selena gomez altro l'altro
giorno mi hanno detto che se non
commetterà firenze dove cazzo ero quindi
ragazzi spero che la vita sia piaciuto
cose e mi piace anche i vari social che
come vivi dotato nella scrittura 06
aversi iscrivetevi e noi ci vediamo
l'anno prossimo mi do da ragazzino